über corona spricht man nicht gerne in
den schweizer bergen
das ist mein erster eindruck
schwellbrunn ein dorf im appenzeller
land das im oktober schlagzeilen macht
weil ein brautpaar 200 gäste zur
hochzeit lädt feier trotz symptomen und
alle schweigen als sich die infektionen
häufen
viele hier halten corona für ein
hirngespinst
sie wollen uns hier was aufdrücken das
einfach nicht stimmt denn die gefahr
dieses video was ist eigentlich wirklich
belegt
andere ärger diese haltung das
schlimmste war nach nach der hochzeit
noch das oktoberfest und alle wochen
später ist noch schwierig dass viele
leute täglich geht das nicht ran
der ort ist gespalten erzählt mir der
dorfwirt corona gibt es bei uns nicht
das war ihr gefühl
bis zu dieser hochzeit werden im ersten
block da und gab es kaum also wirklich
traum infizierte und jetzt es hat
eigentlich gut getan so aufgefasst eines
systems laufen lassen so lange es geht
die devise des dorfes scheint die devise
der ganzen schweiz nicht der bund
sondern die 26 kantone entscheiden hier
in appenzell habe man im sommer die
warnungen von virologen nicht ernst
genug genommen räumt der
gesundheitsdirektor 1
ja das ist so schnell gegen das hat das
kam sehr überraschend also die
temperaturen sind gefallen die leute
sich mir an innenräumen aufgehalten und
dann sind uns die zahl explodiert dann
die richtige reaktion dass die
gasthäuser jetzt immer noch offen sind
der schweizer die schweiz nimmt es sehr
freiheitsliebend das merken wir schon
und wir müssen mit unserer bevölkerung
maßnahmen machen die auch gelebt werden
und so geht die schweiz einen diametral
anderen corona weg als deutschland trotz
doppelt so hohe infektionsraten man
setzt auf eigenverantwortung alles
bleibt offen so lange es irgendwie geht
trotz voller intensivstationen der
gesundheitsminister gelassen skifahren
muss sein
skigebiete können offene haben das ist
das varena dass sie das video verfolgt
haben
mit strengen schutzkonzepte man müsse
jetzt die wirtschaft schützen sagte
finanzminister unumwunden wir können uns
keine zweite block da und leisten dafür
haben wir das geld nicht das heißt wir
müssen risikobasierte maßnahmen treffen
wie findet man das im
französisch-sprachigen westen dort wo
das virus besonders hart zugeschlagen
hat erst als die infektionszahlen
europäische spitzenwerte erreichen
verhängen die kantone einen teil
lockdown die intensivstation an der
genfer uniklinik am limit
man stellt uns bilder zur verfügung weil
die situation noch immer angespannt ist
mitte november sind 20 prozent des
personals an kuwait erkrankt soldaten
springen ein um zu helfen um infizierte
zu drehen
es gibt die politik politiker welche die
wirtschaft vertreten
und da hätte man schon manchmal ein
bisschen lust gehabt die einfach mal
über die durch den spital und über die
intermediate care und die
intensivstation zu führen dass sie ein
versehen was hier eigentlich abläuft
während sich die intensivstationen
füllen verständigt sich die schweiz
völlig unaufgeregt auf regeln für die
triage dr tram er zeigt mir den
sogenannten gebrechlichkeit index in der
schweiz entscheidet der
gesundheitszustand darüber wer einen
platz auf der intensivstation bekommt
und wer nicht
in genf kommt es nicht zu dieser
abwägung weil patienten ausgeflogen
werden können aber hat man zu hoch
gepokert
schlussendlich sehen wir ein reiches
land das wissen wir alle und wir haben
gewisse reserven und die frage stellt
sich dann einfach was ist wichtiger das
wohlwollen der patienten dass man sich
schon diese patienten kümmert und die
wirtschaft die deutsche virologin
isabella eckerle die in genf forscht ist
eine der wenigen die den liberalen kurs
der schweiz offen kritisiert sie hat
fassungslos zugeschaut wie die
sterberate empor schnellte auf das
dreifache des deutschen wertes man sieht
ja einfach an den todesfällen um die
kann man jetzt ja nun mal nicht
wegdiskutieren dass es in der schweiz
eben im vergleich zu anderen ländern
schon halt sehr viel todesfälle gab es
natürlich auch viele menschen mit
vorerkrankungen noch viele ältere
menschen
trotzdem sind es todesfälle die eben
prinzipiell vermeidbar gewesen wären die
zahlen sind rückläufig
also funktioniert das ganze naja also
die zahlen sind rückläufig aber wir
befinden uns eben immer noch auf einem
sehr sehr hohen niveau
zürich am abend restaurants bars kinos
geöffnet und gefüllt obwohl die
infektionszahlen so hoch liegen wie in
deutschen hotspots viele finden den
liberalen kurs der regierung gut aber
ich spüre auch widerstand leisen
widerstand mit anderen freiwilligen
organisiert jurist simon guerin eine
mahnwache für die 382 züricher corona
toten in der schweiz versuchen wir mit
dem virus einen mittelweg zu fahren
das ist normalerweise eine schweizer
zuge der mittelweg und ich schätze dass
auch ich bin moderat aber mit dem virus
gibt es keinen mittelweg
also ich finde dass sich eine
gesellschaft daran bemisst wie sie mit
den schwächsten in der gesellschaft
umgeht und wie ob sie denen hilft und
ich habe den eindruck dass dieses
prinzip er nicht verfolgt wird
sie wollen dass zumindest mehr
diskutiert wird die wirtschaft schützen
und oder die gesundheit die schweiz
versucht einen riskanten mittelweg der
menschenleben fordert